Why is it that some people are so
judgmental? [music] God says in the
Quran, "Oh you who believe, avoid
negative assumption." Indeed, this man
who is known as AK
has been deceiving the Muslim community
and I had this information but it was
not solidified and I didn't want to say
something because I don't want to risk
my over something like this.
>> I already mentioned to you that I'm not
convinced that the Quran is the word of
God. It's the form of God. and who are
sending these monafics who's not just a
kafir who's not just saying I don't
believe he's pretending to be a Muslim
and putting out vague stuff which we
couldn't what's he mean by that oh this
bkari I don't know if it's true or not
everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die that's why
Allah says
you are busy with the body affairs until
you visit the graves brothers and
sisters mid no way the one that we built
is looking to another masid around the
area of no subhan Allah where there's so
many Muslims that do not have somewhere
to pray. This mas is only $500,000 and
any donation that you give will go
towards your because when you enter that
grave nobody's going to remember you
except Allah subhanaa tala so make it
count brothers and sisters and believe
me if every single one of us give
£110,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go but your deeds on your
makyama are not donate to the link
inshallah let's get to the video
>> day 26 no one likes being judged why is
it that some people are so judgmental
[music] God says in the Quran oh you who
believe avoid negative assumption
Indeed, one of my marriages was to a
reaver. We got married and then we went
our separate ways. But then she left
Islam and that was really kind of
interesting to me. It's like I wanted to
[music] understand why she came to Islam
and then she left Islam. Um and then the
whole ISIS thing when that fell apart
that made me question a lot of things as
well.
>> Never have I received any good from you
and this just had doesn't mean to
disbelieve what it means to be
ungrateful. So the first issue is
whether or not you believe hadith in
fact something the prophet said. Now a
lot of people at this point will lose
their minds. But I can personally say I
don't know if it is something the
prophet said. I can put my hands up and
say that I recognize my own ignorance.
That doesn't mean I'm denying the
prophet said this. I'm just saying I
don't know if he did say it.
>> Brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Alhamdulillah. Allah subhana wa ta'ala
always brings the truth to light when
there is falsehood. You guys saw a
couple of weeks ago the smear campaign
that was against done against myself, my
wife, the da bros and whatever that
means. the the term that has been coined
by kufur the enemies of Islam who have
coined this that has been used by si
some of our sisters and a lot of
monafiken why are feminist Muslim Tik
Tokers using this exact term da bros
where did this term come from in August
2024 the term da bros was used for the
first time in 2022 they tried coining
the term acarite bro but it didn't catch
on it was abandoned for da bros in 2024
who are they funded by they are funded
by Pluto educational trust as known as
pet founded in 2010 by Roger van
Zwenberg and Pauline Tiffen. The term da
bros is a term which evolved and has its
origins in peer-reviewed journals which
are funded by radical liberals Pluto
education trust. What was the aim? The
aim is to westernize Islam. Tik Tockers
and others who are trained to use these
terms in order to create a narrative of
corruption when in fact they are the
most corrupt and compromised. They are
not just feminists but radical
feminists. The Muslim Tik Tockers have
become subordinate to the white woman
and kufur. And what is their aim and
objective? To delegitimize, to discredit
the brothers in the da. And I don't know
who they are because everyone's become a
da bro. The one who does calisthenics is
a da bro because he said bismillah
before he start doing press ups. A
brother who's doing food review has
become a da bro. A person doing comedy
shows doing a da bro. Everyone's become
a da bro. You know why? It is a term
that has been coined so they can run
away from accountability. And Allah
subhanaa t says in the Quran and we
speak from this kab, the Quran and the
sunnah. Okay, this is the book that we
judge by. Not your emotions, not your
feelings, not how you feel. I don't care
if you're a man, a woman, a trans, a
piano, or someone that identifies as a
coconut tree. Okay, I don't care. This
kitab is what we judge by. And if you
want to hang me, hang me by the judgment
of this kab. Yes. Subhan Allah.
Everybody jumped on it. Everybody jumped
on it. Why? Because we calling out evil.
When Allah says in the Quran, "Let there
rise amongst you a group of people who
will enjoy good and forbid evil." Allah
subhanaa tala did not say let there rise
among you a group of sinless people to
enjoy good and forbid evil. He said let
there rise amongst you. You know why?
Because and the reason the the reason
they were destroyed was why? Because
they stopped enjoining good and
forbidden evil. So much so they will
come to the prophetam about a issue of
punishment of a capital punishment and
they will come to the prophetam why
because they stopped following the
scripture they came to the mas of Allah
and the messenger of Allah wasallam said
what why did you not go to the Torah why
did you go to your book what does it say
in your book they were trying to divert
the capital punishment you know why
because it's all become two pack only
God can judge me we are being told that
anybody that calls out evil even if it's
coming from me that what is it that if
I'm wrong as alidawa I'm going to
someone's is going to correct him. I'm
going to say, "No, no, no. You're a da
bro. Quran and sunnah bring me evidences
what I've done is wrong." And guess
what? Now you're going to find out
something shocking. Who are these people
jumping on this bandwagon? Da bros. Da
bros. Da bros. Da bros.
You're about to hear something that is
going to leave your jaw dropped. This
man who is known as AK
has been deceiving the Muslim community.
And I had this information, but it was
not solidified. and I didn't want to say
something because I don't want to risk
my over something like this. Now I have
evidences clear audio recordings who has
made this voice recording and told it's
been shared to the community this man is
not only a kafir yes not just a kir not
just somebody who's saying I don't
believe anymore or I I have some doubts
and we can say you know forget me
brothers can come and help no no people
came to help him now what gets more
crazy is he still claims to be a Muslim
and we have evidences recently of him
claiming
that people are messaging and saying
that the Christians and the Jews are
believers. Brother, this is a statement
of kufur. If you're ignorant, there's an
ignorance. You're not ignorant. Aka,
you're not ignorant. You know, you
abused, you became an extremist in your
religion. And the prophetam said,
"Nobody goes to extremes in his religion
except he overtakes you." Okay. You
belong to a specific group. Yes. And you
did some stuff. And there is even some
rumors which I do not know that you were
stopped by the MI5. Yes. And our
religion talks against people like you
not to go to extremes in your religion.
So much so. Yes. Subhan Allah. You are
claiming Subhan Allah that the kab of
Allah is not the Quran is not from Allah
and the prophetam and the the prophets
are historical figures. Don't take my
word for it. Listen now very carefully
from an audio recording from AK. Who
were you trying to deceive? Bro, look
how Allah subhana wa ta'ala exposed
every single one of you guys. You jumped
on the bandwagon. Why? All we said is
don't call to evil. Don't break
marriage, sister. Yes. Smear campaign
started. Yes. Alhamdulillah. My wife
came and shut up everybody. Yes. You
know why? Above me I have Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala. In my hand I have
theab of Allah and behind me I have a
solid woman. Yeah. Okay. When everyone
was doing a smear campaign trying to
mock her. Yes. Alhamdulillah. And the
truth will prevail. Watch this
recordings brothers and sisters and
listen to yourself and ask me this
question. who is funding these people
and who are sending these monafics who's
not just a kafir who's not just saying I
don't believe he's pretending to be a
Muslim and putting out vague stuff which
we couldn't what's he mean by that oh
this bkari I don't know if it's true or
not oh that sounds a bit dodgy
Muslims sorry Allahh clearly says they
are not listen to this audio recording
>> I already mentioned to you that I'm not
convinced that the Quran is the word of
God if it's for God I'm not convinced of
Right.
>> So the prophethhood of the Muhammad was
>> of course from that everything else
should kind of
>> do you understand? So belief in angels
and gyms and like the prophet said like
I believe in prophet Muhammad and
prophet Jesus all the prophets
historically right do I believe that
they were sent by the god you know I
believe he's out there who created
everything. I don't know. Yeah I don't
know. Why are you making a Tik Tok
account and a Instagram account and
pretending to be a Muslim when you was
the reason your ex-wife, the second one
that you was abusing, both of them, left
Islam and then you accuse me that I'm
the reason people leave Islam. I've
touched on this before and I will speak
about in much more detail in the future.
But I was involved in three polygamous
marriages. Three, not two. Three of my
marriage, not two, by the way. And
there's no shame in that. The first one
and the third one were quite toxic. The
second one wasn't. It was a mutual
agreement and we just wanted different
things in life. And the interesting
thing about the second one is she was a
reavert. And when she got divorced about
year after we divorced, she actually
left Islam.
>> Every accusation is a confession. You
was projecting your evil on me. You know
why? Because you deemed yourself to be
that daer guy, whatever you was, and you
used to abuse your wives and you didn't
know how to do da properly. Okay? And
guess what? You think I'm like you,
brother. I'm not you, bro.
Alhamdulillah. I don't abuse my wife.
Okay? I'm not you, bro. Okay? So
alhamdulillah you can see now guys and
everyone in the da scene has to warn
against his guys and I want to make this
clear I wish no harm on this guy in any
way shape or form. So this lies about oh
his life is in danger. Brother Islam
doesn't need you. May Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala guide you back to Islam and the
truth. And if you need da'ah, you don't
need to come to me. There's many people
out there. Alhamdulillah, we ask Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to guide you back to
Islam. Allow you to fix your ideology.
Okay? And allow you to come back to the
huck. You went to extremes in your
faith. And this is what happened. Okay?
You went to extremes. Don't blame no one
but yourself. Okay? You are a train
driver. Okay? in those videos that you
watch in the training all these uh stuff
that you watch on psychology and this
that doing a psychoanalysis of me yes
and who praised and shared her content
we know who I don't need to go into
details okay and one by one yes jama yes
a hadith rejecting kafir she's a woman
who's a kafir who mocks and insults I im
bkari you got k who I'm not doing saying
the prophetam is disgusting
yes and these are that group and then we
have Mr. Kez, who I tried to get to
talk, alhamdulillah, for him to join the
live. You're going to be exposed as
well. You know why? Cuz you are a liar.
You insulted my wife. And a sister on
the live today called you out.
>> Yeah. I don't normally come on guests,
but I just come on to say please,
please, please just talk to Ali. He's
trying to speak to you,
>> sister. Big up sister. Big up sister.
Big up sister. Big up.
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> Big up the sister.
>> He just wants to talk to you.
>> Big up sister. Big up sister. Big up to
all the sisters.
>> Where she gone?
>> Where she WHERE'S SHE GONE? WHERE'S SHE
GONE? SHE DISAPPEARED. [laughter] LOOK,
LOOK, LOOK.
>> Subhan Allah. Look, look, look, look,
look. Where's she gone? Where's she
gone? WE GOT CAUGHT OUT. YOU ADDED HER.
You wasn't adding any brothers in the
fear that it would be me on my live. I
exposed you. The sister came like wall
that this sister is more of a man that
you can ever be. Yes. And called you and
said, "Be a man and speak to Ali Tawa.
All I want to do is talk to you, bro.
All I want to do is talk to you." And
you can see one by one Allah subhana t
is exposing them. And I'm going to end
on this note brother and sisters by
reciting this verse from the Quran
inshallah where Allah subhanaa t talks
about the
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
forch.
And for mankind are some who say we
believe in Allah. and the last day while
they do not believe at all. Okay. Subhan
Allah. Look at him lying that he's a
Muslim when deep down he knows he
doesn't believe in it. Subhan Allah. And
trying to lie and deceive the Muslims.
Subhan Allah. Who is paying you? Who is
paying you? They think to deceive Allah
and the believers. Subhan Allah. Yes.
But it but they deceive not except
themselves and they do not realize it.
In their heart is their disease that
Allah has increased them in their
disease and for them will be a painful
punishment because they used to lie.
Subhan Allah. Subhan Allah. I ask Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala. Yes. Even though
this man has called me names. Yes. Try
to use a da bros to cause fitna among
the community. Subhan Allah. How Allah
subhana wa ta'ala exposed you. How Allah
subhana wa t'ala exposed you. One by one
all of you guys jumped on the bandwalk
and Allahh exposed you. And guess what?
I ask Allahh to guide you back to Islam.
If you want to come and listen I can.
It's in the hands of Allah subhanaa
tala. Wa I'm not saying this out of
arrogance. W I fear I fear for myself.
But let me tell you something. Yeah. You
attacked for no just reason except you
have hatred for the da. And let me tell
you something. Yeah.
We will till the last breath that we
take. We're going to enjoy good and
forbid evil. We're going to call out
those evildoers. And if you don't like
it, tough luck. This is what the kab and
the sunnah calls us to. Okay? And
nobody's going to stop us. No toxic
feminist in your millions, in your
thousands, no simps, no monafics, no
kafir, not none of those who plot and
they plot and Allah plans and he is the
best of planners. So guys, I'm saying it
one more time. I don't want any hate on
this guy. All I'm saying is this is his
reality. be aware and just know these
guys are just tools that's been used to
attack the Muslim ummah within so that
the youth can doubt us for no good
reason except we call to the of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala.
What better?